so baby how did you like australia wait
it was really
dude maybe the dopest place in the world
oh whoa
i like really really liked australia i i
don't know maybe it's because i was
doing uh what's it called uh like a
movie
this festival called laneways and like
it was like every other night was just a
straight party it was it was sick and
you you know the chats like the
the punk band from australia no
the the main like lead singer has like a
really dirty mullet
he's just ginger mullet and uh i know
their music is just like straight like
one minute punk songs and it okay
goes off every every record and uh
we were just like like they're like some
serious like pop stars
out there and they're like punk as hell
so they're like
we were like nikki nikki nine doors at
the hotel the all the
all the people were staying and i was
like dude this is the most aggressive
thing i've ever done
and he was like dude punk punk and i'm
like hell yeah all right so
it was a good time but you you guys are
doing what nikki nikki
is that like a naked hopscotch thing
what is it oh no it's just like you
run in the hallways and you just like
tap on all the doors and you're like
oh like a like ding dong ditch yeah okay
yeah we call it
but you are naked you're supposed to be
you're supposed to be naked well
i mean for the next time next time next
time that's that's a good idea though
because if they come on and you just
turn around you're fully butt naked and
you're like yo like
that wasn't me knocking on random doors
in a hotel is actually very
very hardcore yeah super super hardcore
like i think i think even the toughest
of tough
would be uncomfortable with that that's
[ __ ]
yeah that's a lot that's asking a lot
yeah
spock told me the story about him and
getter when they were on tour
spock got a room one night um
i forget why but uh ghetto oh
his girl flew in for the show so they
got a room for the night and i think
gutter wanted to punk them
because he was assuming that they were
they were smashing
so ghetto goes up to the this hotel room
and he bangs on the door loud as [ __ ]
for like an extended period
the funny part is the spock is on the
floor above and he can hear
that getter's doing this because the way
the hotel is it's like open balcony [ __ ]
but ghetto had the wrong room so spock
is just like hysterical he's like dude
or no i think they told him the next day
and spock is like i didn't hear that
[ __ ] like you must have got the wrong
room
so ghetto was just smashing this door
being like
spock spock wake up
let me hear it just whatever and and
just some random person listening to
that [ __ ] how [ __ ] frightening would
that be
horrifying yeah yes
big start big star trek fan outside
apparently
that's some tour [ __ ] man whatever
happened is ridiculous almost every
single time there's
something ridiculous that happens it's
just
so you had 150 shows lined up for this
year and then yeah i would i would
probably still be on a tour right now
that's intense man
jesus christ it was it was sick because
it was like
my agent was like yo like either there's
two routes we like kind of pull off do
all like festivals or you like you
literally make the biggest statement
of your life doing shows globally
everywhere
and like winning and you know right off
the bat of the the big record la la la
la last year i was just like well that
sounds like the move
and then yeah i blew my voice in
australia
which was really scary and i was like
well i have a 140
more shows after this wow [ __ ] so wow
wait what does that mean what does that
mean in perth like i literally
couldn't perform like i just my voice
like didn't like i
couldn't talk so wow i jumped up on
stage i was like hey guys i can't really
talk
but and then some girl in the crowd was
like i know all your lyrics and i was
like
thank god pulled her off on stage and
she knew every single lyrics to
everything wow
it was sick dude wow yeah so
she just did the show for you yeah
absolutely and people went
crazy dude it was it was tight
it was it was a funny show that's
actually [ __ ] dope
that's so tight took like front row to a
show and you're like this is gonna be
tight he's like guess what dude
my voice sucks today you do it
[Laughter]
yeah i've been practicing i wish we
could do that for a [ __ ] comedy show
could you imagine you guys should have
people just do the jokes
who thinks they're funny in here
[Laughter]
give them the holes they just kill it
give them the whole set
[ __ ]
yeah i can do what you guys do all right
go ahead one hour let it rip
just walk off the stage i'm saying what
if they just like what if they just
murder
like what if they're way better they
have a whole hour comedy special
in the back pocket right you guys have
an opener
no i guess there's no point really no
rap caviar that's our opener we play rap
caviar in the in the
in the theater so sometimes you'd open
for us you know like technically
like yeah i mean no i actually i don't
think i've ever been putting rap caviar
you guys really yeah i know i i like i
don't know
i don't i don't think definitely not us
yeah no definitely not me
i've been in today top hits but that was
just like exclusively
some label word yeah um
you're not assigned to a label though
right no i'm independent
it's not it's you know there's pros and
cons i feel like
i'm a one-man army sometimes and then
other times it's like well i can
literally do whatever i want
that's kind of nice but oh bro my bad
have you ever done anything with a label
uh yeah so we signed la la la to
columbia
because i mean like independently the
song was doing like a million a day
when we signed it and i was like dude i
can't i can't push this song
like i remember the last day right
before we sounded i pushed it for like
14 hours on memes
and i was like dude i can't do this
every day to keep this up like i need
someone
to do do this for me and then like
i didn't really expect a label really to
do anything to be honest i was like
kind of like anti-label of course i mean
everybody is
yeah holy [ __ ] did they take that song
like up to the skies dude
made it they really did dude man i like
the moment i signed it ron perry
legend funny ass dude comes up to me and
he's like hey alex you're in today top
hits like literally five minutes after i
signed and then he like gave me like a
chocolate bar
well i was like nuts yeah that's
ridiculous
worth it
yeah i mean i had a hundred and some odd
shows book because of it right so
it was worth it in the end of the day
man
so i mean even you've been making a lot
of music i feel like since
quarantine started you've definitely
been doing your thing i appreciate you
um dressing up with those big beautiful
cans man um just gotta say man it
changed the way i look at you
i'm just [ __ ] around it's a it's a
really good video
that was a great great [ __ ] music
video that [ __ ] is high art man who
who came up with that um so my
videographer therese
i i was just like yo what do you think
of this song and he's like it sounds
like
something you would listen to in like
you know chicago or detroit like you
know like a house like a house spot
and then we were just riffing and he he
has a
his he went to high school with jimbo
and uh
you know he used to party uh at jimbo's
all the time
back in the day yeah the throw like like
the most
turned up like high school parties all
the time
and he was like thoughts and i was like
sure yeah but i was like as long as it's
done like
really really well and i was like bro
it's like we can't be like slandering
you know drake culture at all
course course like top tier and then
he's like bro like
of course and i was like okay and then
you know i put the course head on
and had bruises around my rib cages
dan yeah i was going to say what was
what was the application on that like
like did it hurt
or um i didn't tuck so
that you know that was fine but i mean
the
it was really uncomfortable what is that
what is that like okay
so i'll give you the the anatomy of
tucking so you you know two testicles
right here
i can guess but yeah i don't wanna put
them so you know how the gooch is right
here and you like you put them like
on top of the gooch yeah you like fold
them into your
crevice and then you like grab the skin
and pull it all the way up into your
[ __ ] and then
with your dick too so you like rub it
all the way up in your [ __ ] hold it
pull up a nylon and it like
tucks damn [ __ ] and
jimbo she was just like yeah like i do
it every day
and i'm like
damn damn
like man after being a drag queen for a
day like
seven hours of makeup seven hours yeah
all right seven hours of makeup it was
so rowdy dude
like you had the i mean well you sat and
you sat and got makeup done for seven
hours straight yeah
and then i did like seven hours of
shooting with a corset and i couldn't
breathe and i was like
incredibly discomforted yeah like
i i have so much respect for queens now
it's like
they do that [ __ ] every day like that's
not just me being like yo
like i'm i'm a wussy but like that's
just
nah that's i don't know it's
it's i mean that's a whole like
man commitment isn't isn't even the word
it's just like
they live that it is [ __ ] respect
dude
that's that's tight though that you uh
what's the song called again called i'ma
like
yeah i was like this [ __ ] should be
on director's library or some [ __ ] like
this whole
this is this is like crazy art [ __ ] dude
it was it was dope
i was beyond um floored by that it was a
hats off man i appreciate it man i uh i
was kind of
like i really wonder you know as far as
my fan base like what they're gonna say
cause like
you know i'm obviously pro drake but
like i don't i can't speak for the rest
of my fan base yeah you don't know if
you're gonna have like some bozos in the
crowd they're like dude what are you
doing man
i mean there definitely was but like 90
i would say like 98
99 of the people were just like yo this
is [ __ ] hilarious this is sick like
yeah i love his boobies
[Laughter]
you i mean they were they were pretty
sick
[Laughter]
more like a [ __ ] double dino money
god damn
dd no money yeah baby no dick baby
you